have you ever wondered what makes Amish
life so unique today I'll take you
inside their world in a time when
technology dominates agriculture the
Amish Stand Out by embracing Simplicity
community and Faith their rejection of
electricity is not merely a stubborn
choice but a deliberate effort to uphold
values like humility and self-reliance
for the Amish farming is about far more
than efficiency it te is about living in
harmony with nature instead of modern
machinery the Amish depend on hand tools
animal power and The rhythms of the
seasons their connection to the land
runs deep they view it as a partner to
work with not an object to control this
difference in approach enables them to
thrive sustainably while preserving
their Heritage through methods honed
over Generations at first glance the
Amish field spread across Scenic
Countryside may seem unassuming but
beneath this modest exterior is a
complex and highly refined system one
that has been perfected over centuries
to work with nature rather than against
I unlike modern Farms which are noisy
with machines and crisscross by
irrigation systems Amish farms offer a
peaceful Stillness the lack of
technology is not a disadvantage but a
carefully considered decision to
maintain a balance with the environment
this philosophy rooted in generations of
experience is passed down along with a
treasure Trove of practical knowledge
the Amish farming methods have evolved
from centuries of observations Hands-On
trials and patience instead of depending
on artificial inputs like synthetic
fertilizers or pesticides they Place
their trust in natural processes and the
land's ability to regenerate itself this
creates a sustainable system resilient
to weather economic fluctuations and
even Global crisis on Amish farms the
Roar of Machinery is replaced by the
rhythmic sound of hoof beats the creek
of wooden harnesses and the low steady
voices of farmers guiding their animals
where Modern Farmers rely on automated
systems the Amish Embrace manual labor
and animal power creating a unique
connection between people land and
livestock horses mules and oxen serve as
the tractors of Amish Fields while
modern Farmers sit in airconditioned
cabs Amish farmers walk behind teams of
strong animals gripping the reins with
experienced hands the image of horses
pulling a plow through dark fertile soil
may look like a scene from history but
for the Amish it is a practical and
efficient way to farm using animals for
labor creates a symbiotic relationship
between the farmer and the livestock
horses are more than tools they are
Partners in the process Amish farmers
spend years training their animals to
work in harmony with the seasons
developing a mutual understanding that
results in seamless cooperation this
collaboration is built on patience and
skill where animals learn to respond to
the farmers's gestures and commands the
connection between the farmer the soil
and the Animals creates a deeply Human
Experience that cannot be replicated by
machines the Amish approach to farming
is both environmentally friendly and
sustainable by using animal power
instead of Machinery they avoid the
carbon emissions and SW compaction
caused by heavy tractors this preserves
the land's natural structure enhances
water retention and reduces erosion
ensuring the Earth remains fertile for
future Generations while this method may
appear labor intensive compared to
modern techniques the Amish embraced the
lower more intentional process as an
essential part of their way of life it
aligns with their values of Simplicity
self-reliance and respect for nature
horses mules and oxen serve as the
tractors of Amish Fields while modern
Farmers sit in airconditioned cabs Amish
farmers walk behind teams of strong
animals gripping the reins with
experienced hands the image of horses
pulling a plow through dark fertile soil
may look like a scene from history but
for the Amish it is a practical and
efficient way to farm using animals for
labor creates a symbiotic relationship
between the farmer and the livestock
horses are more than tools they are
Partners in the process Amish farmers
spend years training their animals to
work in harmony with the seasons
developing a mutual understanding that
results in seamless cooperation this
collaboration is built on patience and
skill where animals learn to respond to
the farmer's gestures and commands the
connection between the farmer the soil
and the Animals creates a deeply Human
Experience that cannot be replicated by
machines the Amish approach to farming
is both environmentally friendly and
sustainable by using animal power
instead of Machinery they avoid the
carbon emissions and SW compaction
caused by heavy tractors this preserves
the land's natural structure enhances
water retention and reduces erosion
ensuring the Earth remains fertile for
future Generations while this method may
appear labor intensive compared to
modern techniques the Amish embrace the
slower more intentional process as an
essential part of their way of life it
aligns with their values of Simplicity
self-reliance and respect for nature for
smallscale irrigation Amish farmers also
employ hand pump water systems these
manual pumps allow for precise control
over how much water is delivered to the
plants while this method requires
physical effort it provides Farmers with
a deeper connection to their crops
encouraging great at attention and Care
the beauty of these irrigation methods
lies in their Simplicity and
environmental sustainability by
utilizing Natural Forces like wind and
gravity and carefully conserving water
resources Amish farmers can cultivate
their field without straining local
ecosystems compared to Modern Farms that
heavily rely on irrigation and overuse
of water tables Amish practices offer a
model of conservation and efficiency
these traditional methods show how
working with nature rather than against
it can lead to healthy crops and a
healthier Planet the Amish approach
preserves the land for future
Generations while producing thriving
harvests it is a testament to the
patients skill and respect for nature
that defines their way of life Central
to Amish farming is their deep
understanding of soil Health a knowledge
build over Generations one of the
cornerstones of this practic is crop
rotation a time honored method that
improves soil quality and promotes a
resilient ecosystem system instead of
planting the same crop in the same spot
year after year of practice that
depletes soil nutrients and attracts
pestil Amish carefully plan crop
sequences different plants have unique
nutrient needs and impact the soil in
varied ways for example legumes like
beans and pead nitrogen to the soil
enriching it for future crops by
alternating such nutrient boosting crops
with those that demand more from the
soil Amish farmers maintain fertile
Fields year after year this approach
creates a balanced ecosystem where
growth and Decay work together to keep
the soil healthy in addition to rotating
crops the yish use natural fertilizers
like livestock manure and compost to
further enrich their land manure
collected from barns is spread across
fields to deliver vital nutrients for
plant growth compost made from organic
materials and plant residues adds
beneficial microorganisms to the soil
improving its structure and fertility
over time these natural methods Ensure
that the soil remains a rich and
productive foundation for future crops
one of the most impressive aspects of
Amish farming is their commitment to
avoiding synthetic pesticides and
herbicides instead they use companion
planting and biodiversity to manage
pests Naturally by planting crops like
maragold next to vegetables they create
natural barriers that repel harmful
insects this approach not only protects
crops but also supports a healthier
ecosystem by attracting beneficial
insects and Wildlife the Amish show that
farming in harmony with nature can be
just as effective and often more
sustainable than modern chemical
dependence Amish farms excel in
promoting healthy ecosystems by avoiding
chemical pesticides and fertilizers this
lack of chemical intervention benefits
not only the soil and plants but also
the well-being of farmers and their
families the resulting food is often
richer in flavor and nutrition free from
the residues and additives commonly
found in conventional agriculture by
creating an environment where nature can
flourish the Amish cultivate a
self-sustaining system that both
preserves the land and produces
delicious wholesome crops within the
Amish agricultural tradition seeds
represent more than just a tool for
planting they are a legacy that connects
generations and secures the future the
art of seed saving is at the heart of
their farming practices uring access to
diverse and resilient plant varieties
that have adapted to local conditions
over time seed saving isn't simply about
preservation it is a skilled practice
Amish farmers carefully select the
strongest specimens from their harvests
focusing on desirable traits like
disease resistance flavor and yield this
deliberate selection process ensures
that only the healthiest and most
adaptable seeds are carried forward
enabling crops to thrive despite
changing environmental conditions air
Loom seeds hold a special place in Amish
communities often passed down through
generations these seeds maintain their
genetic Purity through meticulous
breeding and selection unlike hybrid
varieties which are engineered for
specific traits and may not reproduce
consistently Heirloom Seeds preserve
unique characteristics this diversity is
crucial for resistance to pests diseases
and climate changes enabling Farmers to
adapt while staying true to their
Heritage the Amish approach to seed
saving has significant cultural meaning
each seed carries the stories of their
ancestors reflecting the triumphs and
challenges that have shaped their
farming practices this connection
creates a sense of responsibility toward
their land the community and the
environment by preserving seeds they not
only honor tradition but also promote
biodiversity and sustainability the
practice of passing down seeds through
generations embodies the Amish
philosophy of stewardship children learn
these Traditions from a young age
participating in seed collection and
preparation for future planting Seasons
this Early Education Fosters Pride and a
deep commitment to sustainable farming
ensuring these practices benefit future
Generations in an era dominated by
monocultures and Commercial seed markets
the Amish tradition of seed saving
offers a powerful Testament to the value
of resilience and diversity by
preserving heirloom varieties and
honoring the knowledge of their
ancestors the Amish do more than grow
crops they nurture their community's
identity and future each saved seed is a
promise of sustainability tradition and
connection to the land on Amish farms
green houses are elegant structures
composed of glass and wood these designs
maximize solar energy to extend the
growing season beyond what the outdoor
climate allows green houses reflect
Amish values of sustainability and
resourcefulness operating without
artificial lighting or heating carefully
planned to face South these green houses
capture maximum sunlight throughout the
day the glass panels let sunlight enter
while trapping heat creating a
microclimate that supports supports
plant growth even in chilly conditions
the design is simple but effective
relying solely on Natural Energy a key
feature of these green houses is the use
of thermal Mass water barrels placed
inside absorb heat during the day and
slowly release it at night regulating
temperatures this method provides a
stable environment for seedlings and
young plants without relying on costly
or environmentally harmful heating
systems thanks to these green houses
Amish farmers can begin planting early
in the the spring and extend the Harvest
well into the fall this sustainable
system ensures a consistent supply of
fresh produce and produces robust plants
ready for outdoor transplanting when the
weather warms up as summer Peaks Amish
farms burst with the vibrant colors of
ripening crops a testament to the
efficiency and Ingenuity of their
Greenhouse practices these methods not
only boost productivity but also
celebrate the Amish tradition of working
in harmony with nature the robust plants
that emerge from these green houses are
often remarkable for their resilience
having been nurtured in a meticulously
controlled environment this careful
cultivation results in stronger and more
productive crops when transferred to the
fields as the Summer Sun reaches its
peak Amish farms burst to life with the
vibrant use of ripening crops signaling
the beginning of the Intensive hand
harvesting process unlike modern Farms
that rely heavily on Machinery the Amish
take pride in the art and precision of
harvesting by hand this traditional
method ensures both the highest quality
and a deeper connection to the land hand
harvesting requires a level of attention
and care that machines cannot match each
crop whether Tomatoes corn or beans
Demands a unique approach Farmers
examine each plant with care picking
only the ripened fruits at their Prime
this diligent process results in produce
that is often fresher and more flavorful
than what is typically available in
stores the Hands-On nature of harvesting
allows Farmers to develop a more
intimate relationship with their crops
fostering a sense of pride in their work
and the high quality food they produce
once the Harvest is complete the Amish
turned their attention to preservation a
crucial step to ensure food security
Through The Long Winter months to store
their harvest the Amish rely on
traditional methods such as canning
drying and fermenting often without the
use of electricity these time honored
techniques not only extend the shelf
life of food but also enhance its flavor
and nutritional value canning is a
beloved tradition in Amish homes family
members gather to preserve fruits
vegetables and sauces in glass jars
ensuring that the flavors of the Harvest
can be enjoyed long after the season
ends this process requires diligent
preparation including washing peeling
and cooking followed by the sealing of
jars to lock in freshness the result is
Pantry shelves lined with vibrant jars
that tell stories of hard work and Care
drying is another essential preservation
technique simple tools such as drying
racks or hanging methods are used to
remove moisture from herbs fruits and
vegetables this process intensifies
flavors and retains nutrients providing
nutritious ingredients for Soups and
stews throughout the winter fermentation
is yet another valued practice adding
flavor and tradition to Amish food
preservation foods like sauerkraut and
pickles are fermented to naturally
preserve them while introducing
beneficial probiotics that support
Digestive Health these Preserve Foods
become Staples in Amish kitchens
offering a taste of Summer even in the
depths of Winter the Amish approach to
preservation reflects a deep commitment
to sustainability and quality every jar
of preserved food carries a story of
dedication and respect for the land
transforming seasonal produce into year
round sustenance as winter arrives the
Amish Harvest is not just a memory but a
testament to their hard work and
Community Spirit farming in Amish
culture goes beyond individual efforts
embodying a collective undertaking where
families and neighbors unite to share
the burdens and joys of Agriculture
during harvest season I te common to see
groups of Amish families working
together in the fields these
collaborative efforts go beyond sharing
labor building relationships and
strengthening a sense of belonging
Harvest days often turn into
celebrations complete with storytelling
and shared meals at enrich social ties
Barn raisings are perhaps the most
iconic example of Amish Unity when a
family needs a new Barn the entire
Community gathers to build it te in a
single day this impressive feat of
cooperation reflects a belief in mutual
Aid and responsibility the Amish model
of farming and community life is a
reminder of the power of working
together it offers a Counterpoint to
Modern individualism showing that
Collective efforts can yield greater
success while strengthening social
Fabrics in a technology-driven world the
Amish challenged us to embrace simpler
and more resourceful methods of food
production their sustainable practices
demonstrate how to farm in harmony with
the Earth while minimizing resource
consumption as modern society faces
environmental challenges the Amish way
of life offers inspiration by
incorporating their Timeless techniques
and focusing on community we can
cultivate a future that values the land
nurtures social connections and
reconnects us to the true essence of
food production